- You tweeted this a
bit ago and I love this
'cause it shows so much
of your sense of humor.
But, "I know. I'll run for president.
I'll make some romantic music.
Everybody will get laid. And
everybody will be happy again."
(audience laughs)
I'll make some romantic
music. Everyone will get laid.
And will be happy again. There
is some truth to that, Barry.
Some real truth.
- I'm your guy.
- I would vote for you.
I think it's a good plan.
Would you ever run for--
Would you ever do anything
in political field?
- Never, never, never.
- I always think, "why do you do that?"
It's like coaching a Texas football team.
It's like all the coaches, it's
like, when they're winning,
they're like, "Oh, it's the
team. You just lucked out."
And then when you're losing,
then the coach sucks.
It's like, you can't win.
- Listen, it's a very, very
complicated thing to do.
I, you know, I got my
own opinions, but no,
I never, never get even near that.
- I think most artists
are too unfiltered, too.
I think that you have to have
like this polish about you
and artists are generally
like, "No, this is how I feel."
- Right.
- Yeah, this is what I really
wanted to say, so I said it.
- No. I just want to
make people feel good.
And that's where I stopped.
(audience applauds)
- I think that making music
that people get laid to is
amazing. I think job well done.
Those are some positive
footprints you're leaving
in this world.
All right, I'm with you.